[Music]
hello everyone welcome to
talk to you about the cloud over a series
of short videos
we will present the
main bricks used for the
migration of a client with a stack
lamp to the cloud
my name is  bruno reboul i am an
engineer within the
professional services organization entity of
google cloud
in this episode we will help
fantastic start-up tricotin to solve
a difficult equation how to
quickly deploy changes in production
without compromising the stability of the
website indeed  to remain a leader
fantastic knitting must continually innovate
improve its site resolve
malfunctions at an unbeatable speed
at the same time if users
love fantastic knitting it is
also and a lot because the site is
super
reliable reliability is the first and the  most
important features so the
deployment process is at the heart of
success  you have to know how to deploy quickly and
stable how to do a whole automate
the tasks the tests both always
deployed very gradually
for that we will use google
cloud bild which is the service manager
google cloud to host their
'pipeline' propellers of the fantastic knitting site
in mode  cia sidi continuous integration
continuous deployment how it
works
first of all we
use build flahaut native integration
with git step one as
developer of fantastic knitting site
i will record code change
with command git had
guide like it
and push this modification from my
post to the google cloud source repository
we see that this action
automatically triggers a bill why
because we have configured this trigger
as we see it this one listens to
any modification on the guide branch
that interests us and launches steps
of build defined in this file yamal
let's look  in more detail
we used this hamel file to
define a bespoke workflow
as a series of steps
for the simplicity of the demo here we have
a step which is to make
a docker image and publish it to
google  containers registry
thus we concretely facilitate the
containerization of the
fantastic knitting application but by the way
what are containers and why
containerized a transport container
is a standard format box which
greatly facilitates its handling
without worrying about  its content for us a
container is a version of our
application well configured with its
dependencies in a package that is ready
to be executed it can be executed
both on my
development workstation and on a production server
once package and for one version
given we modify it the more the container
is immutable it thus brings a lot
of stability and avoids disappointments
during the transition to pro
duction moreover it is much lighter
and simpler to manufacture than a
virtual machine because it does not contain the
operating system
it is therefore also resource-efficient
it loads very quickly while
remaining sealed vis-à-vis others
applications as we see
the container build step
first uses a build hours here docker
cloud bild offers several
ready-to-use builders but above all there are
more builders offered by the
community such as theraform for example
it is therefore  possible to simply create your
own mulder
finally we publish the result of
the build process our
knitting application docker image directly in
google containers registry
so every time the developers
push the code ready to deploy
from git cloud build automates the
laborious work  the famous toy that
could be translated by corvée in French
so that the containerized application is
built is p  then aim to be
automatically deployed in our different
dave test prod environments in summary
we used google cloud sources
to host the co2
git repositories google cloud build to
automatically build our docker containers and
google containers registry to store
the core images produced by these three
services are entirely managed by the
google cloud teams so that
the developers of le tricotinfantastique
can devote their time to innovating and
improving the site and not to managing their
own platform 6 6/10
these three services actively participate
in building a deployment process
automatic is configurable a
next step here would be to add
steppes in the stack file in order
to enrich the process in particular with
the automation of unit tests of
quality control of code control
of integration and acceptance tests
so we  attract a real ability
to deploy quickly  and stable to close this
episode on google claude wild and
containerization take a look at
the description of this video you
will find additional resources
to deepen this subject thank you
for listening to us so far and see you soon
[Music]